tuesday two o'clock and they were
rigging edinburgh hogmanay's main stage
a glance at the news and suddenly the
job changed
riggers began de-rigging
scotland's famous party was over before
it started as its first minister
announced a 500 limit on outdoor crowds
among a new raft of restrictions this is
not a choice between protecting health
and protecting the economy if we don't
stem the spread of the virus both health
and the economy will suffer
losing its hog many events is a hammer
blow to this city that's two years
running that coved has caused their
cancellation and these events are worth
40 million pounds to the local economy
for whom the bell tolls
the bell was tolling for emra's council
leader as we prepared to interview him
appropriately this will be disappointing
crucially of course it'll be
disappointing to the people of edinburgh
particularly young people who are
looking forward to attending
a lot of these events and
you know
i i absolutely recognize that that
disappointment if it was playing in
front of very very limited funds i would
of course i would rather not play and
play in front of a big crowd in those
games hundred percent
uh
the but i'm saying i don't see the
reasoning if that is the case
hypothetically
is why would you say this rule is really
important in four days three days time
but not tomorrow night i don't see the
reasoning at all and i don't see the
sense in it
[Music]
crowd limits outdoors differ from
indoors there it'll be 100 standing and
200 city it'll be one metre social
distancing and table service where
alcohol is on sale
some in the night time industry complain
it amounts to closure by stealth in
practical terms how you would actually
do an event that was one meter socially
distance that was standing seems to be
nigh on impossible it's pretty clear
that um club night's effectively been
banned and probably most kinds of gigs
as well we agree that there's a public
health need that needs to be met it just
can't turn into the permanent closure of
venues
the new measures in scotland will last
for three weeks after christmas day a
new year as hard as the old one
james matthews sky news edinboro